[Music]
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalist kitchen clutter seems
to invade our counters cabinets and
refrigerators with ease but it's not
really out of sight out of mind because
the longer we hide all that clutter the
more it stresses us out today on the
public podcast we're going to discuss
decluttering our way to a simple kitchen
a kitchen that helps us nourish our
bodies with our friend max lugavir
author of the new cookbook genius
kitchen i'll hold it up here if you're
watching on youtube it's a cookbook
with tons of simple recipes but also
it's much more about nourishing your
body it's not just about uh well it's
not just about cooking we'll get into
the book here in a moment this thursday
on the minimalist private podcast max
ryan and i
we're going to talk about the most
minimalist foods what foods to eat and
what foods to avoid for simple health
max is also going to critique all of our
office snacks
i had alabama bring them up here
and max i want you to go in i want you
to go in hard i saw him pile it up i was
like oh melbourne must be hungry
y'all could check that out patreon.com
the minimalist your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck
max welcome back to the show brother
honored me thank you guys for having me
dude it's great to have you welcome to
the new studio beautiful thank you thank
you i am i've been eager to have this
conversation because i think one of the
places that clutter really builds up in
our homes are places where it's easy for
us to hide clutter
the kitchen
and so
quite often we can have a pristine
looking kitchen but then also we're just
cramming stuff into shelves and the more
storage space we have the more
opportunities we have for cluttering our
lives
and i think that's especially true in
the kitchen space and so this is a
listener driven show i thought we would
get right to our questions and we could
talk about some of this kitchen clutter
our first question today is from melanie
on facebook what kitchen appliances are
essential for healthy eating at home
air fryer air fryer
next question air fryers are great
airfar they you can cook whatever you
want in minimal time without uh added
oils and stuff like that so it's from a
health standpoint i'm definitely pro
that's great i was like i was just kind
of throwing a joke out there because i
feel like my brother just got one he
loves it oh yeah mariah and i have one
too we used it all weezy last night but
it's funny how like every two years i
feel like there's always this appliance
that comes out that's like the invoke
thing so before air fryers it was the uh
the pot not the instagram the instant
pot yeah right and then before the
instant pot it was what i don't know
george foreman girl or something i was
gonna say the george foreman girl then i
was like nervous that was gonna date me
that was like
that came out in the 90s or something
right yeah yeah it did it did anyway
anyway well can we talk about this max
so i think when we're talking about the
essential appliances what we really want
to talk about is what is not essential
what is a lot of junk that we put into
our kitchens i mean i think the average
person can go to their kitchen right now
and they find a bunch of things they
haven't used in the last 90 days they're
not going to use in the next 90 days
that's our seasonality rule that's
probably a good indicator that you can
let go of it but what are some things
i'm thinking bread maker right away
for some reason i got three bread makers
during my my wedding yeah interesting i
don't eat bread so that's a problem
interesting well i feel i don't want to
offend anybody i mean you know rice
cooker is one of those things that's
probably extraneous like you can easily
make rice with a pot and a lid yeah i
used to before i bought a water boiler i
was boiling water to make my coffee in a
in a saucepan and every time my
assistant would come over she'd make fun
of me
because
it just looks it's like such a humble
way to do things but i actually found it
to be pretty
uh fun to do that because i have a
what's called a thermapen it's like this
instant read thermometer which no you
don't necessarily need but i do think
that it makes life better in the kitchen
it's also really cool to have especially
if you're a food nerd like i am
and so i would make sure that the water
that i was boiling because you could
easily test the water temperature was
200 degrees which is the perfect
temperature to make coffee you don't
want to go above that you don't want to
go below it yeah um
so yeah i mean when thinking about
things to get out of the kitchen my the
first place that my mind went to was
plastic plastic utensils
plastic storage containers yeah i did a
big purge a couple years ago where i got
rid of all of my plastic tupperware and
i went and i bought a bunch of pyrex um
glass
storage containers to store stuff in
because even though they're heavier
they're not disposable they are
chemically inert which this you can't
say the same about plastic storage
containers
especially when you're storing
wet acidic salty foods in and when those
plastic containers
start to show wear and tear those are
signs that there's a pretty good chance
that that plasticizing compounds are
making their way into your food
so getting rid of the plastic i think is
is really important and they take up a
lot of space so yeah there's so much
plastic too i mean everything from the
disposable plastic stirrers that we use
at different
gas stations or restaurants or wherever
and the plastic silverware all the stuff
is going to leach into our food
especially using it to cook or to stir
something hot and that becomes a problem
so i think plastic's a great place to
start i'm trying to think of some things
that i use there are probably three real
essential things that i use i use an pot
i often cook rice in it but we also use
it to cook other things stews and things
like that yeah cast iron skillet is the
go-to every day yeah yeah as an
essential i was gonna i was gonna say
that because you can cook so many things
in it there's this misconception that a
lot of people have that cast irons are
not nonstick and if you don't take care
of it properly that's true it will be
messier to cook things like eggs but if
you season a cast iron pan which i talk
about actually in genius kitchen um it
actually turns it into a wonderful
nonstick cooking utensil you can cook
steaks in it it's so versatile you can
cook eggs in it and the more you use it
the better it gets which is so great i
actually i remember having a cast iron
pan that my that my mom used that was
passed down to her from her grandmother
from from her mother which i don't know
how long it was in
in her hands but i know that was just
like this family heirloom essentially
wow wow my family for decades that's
amazing yes and the thing about cast
iron pants that's so great is that
they're for the most part chemically
inert although they actually can
increase the iron content of your food
which is a valuable
nutritional i guess bonus aspect of it
for premenopausal women um anybody who's
uh iron deficient anemic which is a
major problem i think one in four
yeah one in four people globally is
anemic and about half of those cases are
due to iron deficiency um so it's a
major it's a major uh global health
problem also people who are on low meat
diets vegans vegans vegetarians are also
prone to iron deficiency um so a cast
iron pan is actually a a worthwhile way
of increasing the iron content of your
food yeah i like how you can stick it in
the oven if you need to like it's finish
a steak finish the steak oh it's
yeah
yeah i think where people get caught up
it is it isn't the gimmicky stuff right
it's like you see the george foreman
grill you see the insta pot you see the
air fryer
you see a bread maker and you feel like
oh i've got to have each of these things
but it's there's really not a right one
to get it's really about like how do you
and your family eat what meals are you
cooking because instant pot for example
like mariah and i don't own one but uh
my friend has one and like every time i
go over for dinner they basically cook
everything on an instant pot and it's uh
yeah and it works great for them yeah i
think the best meals are the ones where
there's minimal you use minimal utensils
to cook them right and then there's
minimal cleanup cleanup i think is the
worst part it's the most
intimidating aspect of home cooking and
we know that home cooking is valuable
from a number of different standpoints
research shows that when people cook
home more they tend to have healthier
bmi so they're at less risk for obesity
they have healthier body fat percentages
they have better cardio metabolic health
and they also there's improved you see
improved family dynamics among people
that cook at home more because cooking
is such an amazing way to show love
right yeah like i love i love nothing
more than bringing my brothers over we
cook dinners together communally my
sometimes my friends will come over and
join in it's such a great um
it's such a great habit to get into also
the food that you cook at home is
healthier you can cook the same meal at
home that you would get out at a
restaurant it's gonna have less calories
overall fewer fat calories and less
sodium yeah so
you know so i think it's a it's a really
amazing
leverage point for better health but
again it's like the cleanup that that
makes people
that that i think is one of the more
intimidating aspects of home cooking so
utilizing like a single pan or a single
sheet pan you know using your oven
cooking a bunch of things like sometimes
i'll throw a piece of fish
uh or actually i'll start with
vegetables because vegetables take
longer to cook they take longer to to
cook they take some time to caramelize
so you can cook some veggies like some
of my favorites are roasted sweet
potatoes or brussels sprouts or even
broccoli cauliflower toss them in some
extra virgin olive oil garlic powder
salt pepper you throw them on a sheet
pan you cook them about 350 degrees for
i don't know you can go for an hour and
then the last 20 minutes you want to
throw on like a piece of fish all you've
used is one sheet pan and you've got
this amazing meal right yeah that's
awesome i think that's when we're
talking about minimalism here we're
talking about
getting rid of the extraneous anything
that's superfluous and now you can
identify what is superfluous for you and
so it's not that there are a strict
three or five or seven essentials
because what is essential for me may be
complete junk for ryan he's like man i'm
never going to use a cast iron skillet
or whatever and if that was the case
then you wouldn't want him to have it
right i remember a house that i lived in
a few years ago my wife and daughter and
i moved into
this was in montana and when we moved in
it was about i don't know seven eight
months in we needed to microwave
something i realized we didn't have a
microwave but it's just because we never
ever used it up until that point and so
a microwave was not essential for us
for someone else it may be essential for
them and so the question is
if you go through all of the things in
your cabinets have i used this in the
last 90 days am i going to use it within
the next 90 and if not you can give
yourself permission to let go because
now you're just holding on to stuff that
maybe someone else could get value from
if you decided to donate it or let go of
it yeah did you end up getting the
marker with uh no but the apartment we
live in now has one and so like i
wouldn't personally ever buy a microwave
yeah um but i i would
uh i'll use it from time to time out of
convenience or we have one at the office
here it's in the shared sort of
kitchenette that we have and so um
although would you advise against
microwave use yeah that's it um i don't
personally use my microwave very often
although
uh the research that i've seen you know
i don't want people to be afraid of
their microwave
um i personally don't use it very often
because
one thing that i've learned while
becoming a better chef over the past and
i wouldn't call myself a chef but i one
thing that i've learned over the course
of becoming a better cook
over the past i don't know decade of my
life
is that we really have to embrace low
and slow cooking
which is sort of a culinary art form
that's been lost because today we're
always on the go right we want our food
like an hour ago right and so
the microwave i think yeah it's a great
way to heat up the water molecules in
your food right but it doesn't it's not
it's not a
i would probably use it more for
reheating food than for than for cooking
food a lot of people will cook like you
know instant frozen dinners in their in
their microwaves and stuff like that
that's not something that i typically do
yeah yeah i also i'm also concerned
about what microwaving is going to do to
um lipids which is something that i i
interesting yeah i mean i would be i
would feel comfortable microwaving for
example vegetables and sweet potatoes um
actually i do do that sometimes because
cooking a sweet potato in the oven can
take a really long time so veggies and
stuff like that i'm actually more
amenable to cooking in a microwave
however
it's fattier foods like foods that
contain
compounds that could potentially be
oxidized especially lipids like you know
polyunsaturated fatty acids um
cholesterol i would be probably less
inclined to put those to to put foods
that
are richer in those components in the
microwave interesting the slow cooking
made me think of the suvi which my wife
and i use like pretty much every day
yeah that is yeah that's amazing what's
amazing to me is like you have this
water set at a certain certain
temperature you could stick your finger
in there and like it's it's not scalding
but yet it's cooking the food i don't
know it's really fascinating to me uv is
a is a pretty good way of adding plastic
to your food i don't know oh yeah that's
just with the bag yeah i should do a
glass there are glass suv are there yeah
yeah but that that's pretty rare and
that's reason we stopped using the sous
sous-vide because
you're wrapping your food in plastic
well yeah i mean we yeah you're right i
mean we do have these like reusable bags
that allegedly silicone is fine yeah
that's that's what it is they're like
silicone is chemical let me ask you real
quick about um non-stick stuff so like
teflon
uh is is it true that like that stuff
eventually gets in your food kind of
like plastic eventually gets in your
food yeah so teflon teflon is is made
using a compound well it's a category of
compounds called pfas substances
actually to say substances is a little
redundant because it stands for per and
polyfluoroalkyl
related substances so it's sort of like
saying atm machine
it's uh it's a bit of a misnomer but um
but these substances are well known to
be endocrine disrupting compounds and
i wouldn't be too concerned with using
it
occasionally however in real world
cooking conditions and kitchen
conditions right
nonstick pans are usually we don't care
for them the way that they ought to be
cared for i've i can't tell you how many
times i've been at friends homes
and they have non-stick pans and they're
using metal
utensils
on them which is not something that you
want to do also people tend to stack
because of the limited storage space in
a kitchen right they tend to stack other
metal
cooking tools on top of the non-stick
pan so that leads to chipping wear and
tear so you definitely
don't want to use a teflon pan that
shows any sign of i mean i personally
wouldn't use a teflon pen in my own home
but um with regard to any non-stick pan
you don't want to use it if there's any
wear and tear and and under real world
conditions there just tends to be a lot
of wear and tear yeah yeah you're not
you don't really want to use a a
dishwasher to
clean them and most people do you don't
want to overheat them most people do
they get hot really easily and really
quickly yeah um so that is the problem
that they that they leach these
endocrine disrupting and and potentially
cancer-causing
carcinogenic compounds into your food
and so that's why i don't recommend the
use of
non-stick pans there is a brand
out there that makes a non-stick pan
that they claim is free of pfast
chemicals okay um
i haven't like vetted their claims or
anything like that i do have one of
these pans in my house and i'll use it
very occasionally for certain like egg
dishes like that's pretty much all that
i'll use that pan for but in general i
primarily will try to get by with a with
my cast iron yeah and i think you know
an important thing to note too is like
you mentioned before with the proper
care the proper cooking technique pretty
much anything can be a non-stick a
non-stick pan really yeah yeah my wife
and i we bought some
uh i forget where we went to get him we
brought him home and i opened it up um
and we were we were had our eyes on the
non-st or yeah on the teflon open it up
and they were we got the wrong box
so um i was like well let me look up and
see you know and like after doing some
research everything that well most of
what you said about the carcinogens and
cancer causing i was like well maybe it
is good that we got the the regular
metal pans and like with the right
seasoning like they are awesome like
there is yeah it's very very much like a
tough one if when we use it right
yeah i mean i just think what a shame it
is that people that are that are taking
the time and taking the effort to cook
at home are then exposing themselves
unwittingly in most cases to
environmental toxins like pfas chemicals
like
phthalates like uh bisphenol compounds
that are ever present in the modern
kitchen right yeah but all it takes is
minimizing
the use of plastic getting rid of the
non-stick pans
and you're really doing your your
endocrine system uh a favor by um by
getting by minimizing your exposure to
those chemicals they're called um
they're called
forever chemicals because they just they
continue to persist in the environment
we don't humans don't break them down
they don't biodegrade oh wow yeah so
they're a major environmental problem
there was a mark ruffalo film a couple
years ago about
uh about this and just how how
treacherous and scary it really is um
and industry doesn't care you know and
also
there's not even good
the the way that they affect the body i
think we might have even touched on this
on the last time that i was on your guys
show but
typically with toxins and this is what
makes an uh endocrine disruptors so
so dangerous is that typically with
toxins or with any chemical the dose
makes the poison right
but with endocrine disrupting compounds
they follow a toxicity curve that's
non-monotonic meaning
they
might be toxic at a at a at a low dose
go quiet at a certain dose and then show
a completely different effect at a
higher dose so this low dose toxicity is
what's unusual right because the
toxicity
curve of of every other toxin is linear
right right there's a certain threshold
beyond which a compound becomes
dangerous and underneath that it's
assumed to be not dangerous or maybe
even beneficial right because we have
this concept of hormetic stress right
which is why which is how exercise
benefits us which is how certain plant
compounds like curcumin and turmeric
just as an example benefits us right
it's like it would be toxic at very very
high doses but at lower doses it
actually provides a a beneficial effect
because it's it spurs
uh protect a protective response in the
body which we benefit from yeah um
these synthetic man-made
in uh endocrine disrupting compounds
they follow a curve that's more u-shaped
which is very unusual and it makes them
very difficult to study and this is one
of the reasons why there's debate right
even in this within the scientific
community about how worried we ought to
be about these compounds so but you
don't have to worry about it if you are
you're avoiding it all together exactly
i'm not worried about teflon in my house
because it doesn't exist in my house
i'm not worried about the bread maker in
my house because it doesn't exist in my
house and i'm not worried about anything
i haven't used in the last 90 days
because if it's there we let go of it
now i will say this
being married with a child we have more
things in our tiny kitchen than i would
if i was a single dude although it
wouldn't be appreciably different i
don't think i think the fundamentals and
i think that gets back to the heart of
melanie's question here what are the
fundamentals for you maybe it's a
stainless steel
skillet
or pan right yeah maybe it's a cast iron
skillet maybe it's an instant pot maybe
it's some sort of rice cooker maybe it's
a a air fryer yeah maybe it is a george
foreman grill i don't know i don't have
one of those things this actually worked
pretty good but anyway i don't own one
but
and the question is like what are you
actually going to use and if it's i am
going to use the george foreman grill
every day no i don't know there's
probably all kinds of teflon on that oh
yeah but if there's a a non-toxic
equivalent to that that we want to laugh
at and sort of sneer and say it's silly
fine but if you're going to use that
thing every day
then that seems to me to be the most
essential thing for you yeah i do want
to move on to our callers here if you
have a question or comment for our
podcast you can call us
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast at theminimalists.com
looks like we have a question here from
laura in pennsylvania my question has to
do with
something we
we have to handle on a day-to-day basis
which is cleaning our homes
and i'm wondering if the two of you
would be
interested in sharing what you use
from a middle minimalist perspective
so max laura here wants to know about
cleaning and i thought this was an
appropriate question for you because one
of the things we do we try to be really
healthy and keep everything clean and
then we use all these really toxic
cleaners in our kitchens and on our
devices and and quite often we're
spraying our fruit with things and all
of this different stuff and i want i
wanted to talk to you about obviously we
want to avoid sort of foodborne
illnesses and so we want to be safe
let's talk a bit about cleaning and food
safety here yeah it's an important topic
um
well
typically
we're not hunters at least most of us
are not
um we're not gatherers and so most of
the food that we buy is coming from a
modern supermarket and we we've lost our
connection to where our food comes from
essentially when we go to the
supermarket and we put things in our
shopping cart we bring them home
with regard to
animal products fish and things like
that
surfaces are really where bacteria can
congregate
and so you want to make sure that your
food is well cooked from the standpoint
of of the surface temperature right but
internally i think we as a culture have
gotten into this habit of overcooking
our food yes which is a which is a major
problem um certainly from a culinary
standpoint possibly also from a health
standpoint right um
but uh but yeah i'm not a big advocate
of overcooking your food provided that
you're cooking it properly and you're
cooking the the external surface and
with regard to
cleaning utensils um and cleaning
products and sprays specifically
i actually there's a
you can use vinegar vinegar is a great
antimicrobial
it's not good at killing viruses but at
a certain at a certain concentration
vinegar is actually a great um and
totally non-toxic way to clean surfaces
in your kitchen
wow
yeah i uh
i typically you know i'll char the
outside of of red meat if i'm cooking it
chicken certainly you want to make sure
it's thoroughly cooked but even chicken
just to just to give you an example
people have this fear about eating
undercooked chicken and i'm not just to
be clear i'm not recommending that
anybody go out and eat undercooked
chicken but the reason why
chicken is so much more dangerous from a
food safety standpoint than beef is not
because of anything inherent to a
chicken right
it's that
because food production has become so
mechanized right and it's done so
swiftly from the standpoint of an
industrial meat production chickens have
small bodies right they're quickly
eviscerated right and the the
possibility of fecal contamination on
the flesh of of of chicken of raw
chicken is so high whereas on a cow it's
much different right
so with chicken it's just a lot more
easy to catch a foodborne pathogen than
it is with beef but if you look to
certain parts of the world like in japan
they eat chicken sashimi it's called
tarashi oh wow yeah that actually exists
in japan yeah so there's nothing
inherently dangerous about it's the the
problem is that modern food right we've
become so disconnected from our food and
that's why
it's very dangerous in the in the you
know in the modern world um if you're
shopping in a modern supermarket and
buying poultry you definitely want to
make sure that it's well cooked yeah
i've heard of people eating raw pork
which
sounds crazy to me too
i think it's it's the same thing though
because what we're talking about here it
part of it is just the western palette
is so familiar with
cooked heavily cooked overcooked meats
yeah charred foods charred broccoli all
of these things that are that are so
heavily cooked when you watch videos of
the hadza and the first thing they do is
like go for a raw liver after hunting an
animal like a deer
and you realize like oh they're actually
prizing the raw liver because of its
nutrient density and we're gonna
actually talk about that quite a bit on
the maximal episode this week i want to
talk about paleo diets and vegan diets
how can we how can we optimize our our
nutrient density because we put these
labels on things and not really step
back and think am i actually nourishing
myself
because you can be incredibly nourished
on one version of a paleo diet and you
can be really deficient on another
version of that same diet and so
what we're talking about here is yes
being safe with our food you're cleaning
the kitchen i use a simple like myers
or
um dr bronner's something that is one of
these natural cleaners and just a little
bit of soap and water and that cleans
the counters just fine i don't need a
bunch of
antibacterial sprays i don't need bleach
on my countertops
yeah you know i shared a recipe recently
on uh i shared a buffalo wing recipe on
my on my instagram recently um because a
lot of people have this idea it was
around uh the super bowl and people have
this idea that buffalo wings are
inherently unhealthy right but there's
actually nothing inherently unhealthy
about them you can bake them you can
make a sauce using healthy ingredients
you can get high quality chicken
so i actually i love to eat buffalo
wings great protein source great source
of collagen vitamin k2
and of course they're delicious but a
lot of people i think when i shared it i
got a lot of feedback people were
shocked that i didn't rinse my chicken
first this is something that i guess
people do they rinse their meat before
they before they cook it which is not
something that you should do there's
there's no need to rinse your meat or to
clean it in any capacity beforehand in
fact in so doing you're actually
increasing the possibility that you are
going to spread
uh whatever bacteria is on the surface
wow throughout your kitchen on you know
onto surfaces so
you definitely don't want to rinse your
chicken
rinse your beef fish
there's
there's no need um laura if you want a
podcast to listen to while you are
cleaning your kitchen i'm gonna send you
a copy of our love people use things
event in new york city we just uh we're
on tour we did an event with tk coleman
and seth godin it was one of my favorite
events
you can check out all of our previous
events at theminimalists.com
previous if you want to listen or watch
any of those events but laura we'll send
you a copy of that
uh do we have anything from the live
stream any questions maybe we could tap
into alabama we do we have a few we'll
start with lauren's question how do you
cut down on food in the house when
fridges and pantries are overflowing
i think this is a common problem what is
it that americans throw away what
percentage of their their groceries like
for up to 40 percent oh it's massive and
it's a major source of greenhouse gas
actually oh wow yeah i mean people love
to argue about dietary patterns that are
more supportive of environmental health
right it's actually i mean you'd be
doing the environment such a huge favor
by simply not wasting food
it's a it's a massive problem well
actually one of the reasons one of the
studies that i stumbled upon that um
inspired me to to write genius foods my
first book was a tufts university
study that found that
uh there's this advice that is still
echoed amongst those in the nutritional
orthodoxy that really to be healthy just
eat all things in moderation but this
study actually found contrary evidence
that people who adhere to this
eat everything in moderation advice
actually tend to eat a lot more junk
food they're more likely to consume
sugar sweetened beverages which we know
is not good for us
confectionary products and the like they
found in this study that the healthiest
people buy a narrower range of of more
healthful foods and they just buy those
foods on loop
so to me
that's what i do i go to the supermarket
and i know that there are certain
staples that i want to have in my house
at all times
wild salmon which is now you can find it
in the freezer section right at major
wholesale retailers
um
eggs a wonderful i call eggs a cognitive
multivitamin because an egg yolk
literally contains everything that
nature has deemed important to grow a
healthy brain
dark chocolate love having dark
chocolate in my house it's a crowd
pleaser if you have kids kids love it um
so many so many great things to have for
me honeycrisp apples i'm always
uh i love apple season i'm such a big
fan of honeycrisp so that's basically it
is i go to the supermarket i already
have a list
quasi-written in the back of my in the
back of my mind and it's also like for
the same reason that you guys
wear the same things every day yeah
right it it's like it reduces decision
fatigue it reduces analysis paralysis so
i think that that's a really important
part of um
of buying narrower things of making your
time in the supermarket easy
you could also there are simple um hacks
that you can use like shopping around
the perimeter i think i mean this is
fairly common knowledge for people who
are
already health conscious but
supermarkets are all designed the same
way you have the fresh perishable food
on the outskirts of the supermarket
because that's where the refrigeration
is and it's the aisles where you find
the shelf stable package processed foods
now there are some good things in the
aisles not gonna lie extra virgin olive
oil we found in the aisles vinegars i'm
a huge fan of vinegar spices salts you
know peppers things like that but it's
the it's the perimeter of the
supermarket where you find the beef you
find the eggs you find the poultry you
find the fish you find the produce
fruits and vegetables and so
to me that's i think the the easiest way
to cut down on what actually ends up in
your in your shopping cart
you have a few go-to's whenever i go so
it's like
organic grass-fed ground beef
rice white rice specifically
um japanese sweet potatoes because i can
tolerate them um when i eat them they
don't cause a whole bunch of
inflammation
and there are a few other staples but
avocados lemons limes
lots of salt
himalayan sea salt yeah and and those
same things like just stay on the list
every time i go and then there may be
things sort of on the periphery there
but there's a handful half a dozen
things that i'm getting every single
time but that really does prevent that
decision fatigue i know what i'm getting
when i go there and if i need something
else it'll also be on the list one other
thing i do is i don't buy anything that
isn't on my list that saves me money
because it prevents all impulse buys
even if i get there and i'm like oh i
really meant to put blueberries on the
list i'll refuse to buy them
just to
create that that little bit of
resistance for me so i'm not
overspending on impulse purchases when i
go to the grocery um yeah i think that's
smart there are also other supermarkets
that that kind of take the decision
fatigue aspect
out of it or at least dial it down like
there's trader joe's which i don't know
if that's if it's available to everybody
who's listening to this but um
but you know instead of having 12
different varieties of peanut butter
they have two right i think is
a lot easier i mean i definitely suffer
from this too my kitchen is packed with
with things mostly because i get sent a
lot of products which i enjoy i enjoy
trying different things occasionally but
if i don't enjoy something
i will usually try to
i won't throw it out because again
that's food waste we want to minimize
food waste but i have i have neighbors
like there's a 12 year old boy that
lives that lives part of the
within the complex that i live in and uh
i'm always like offloading products that
i get sent to him he loves it
yeah yeah it's it's awesome yeah and
then the other thing to think about is
expired food right we did a whole
episode on expired things in our lives
we talked about some expired food in our
kitchens and and other things actually
podcast john i think you put a link to
that in the show notes the episode we
did about expired things we also talked
about expired relationships in our lives
expired
possessions outside of the kitchen as
well shout out to our patrons we'll get
back to some more live stream questions
and comments during the maximal episode
this week but first ryan what time is it
you know what time it is it's time for
the lightning round where we answer your
text messages you can text your
questions your comments your smart
remarks too
937-202-4654 yes indeed now max as you
know during the lightning round this is
where we and our guests we try to answer
questions with a short shareable less
than 140 character response we put the
text to these minimal maxims in the show
notes so people can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media if they
like and now thanks to our good friend
jessica lynn williams social jess you
can find all of our minimal maxims in
one place minimalmaxims.com
we have a question today from jessica
not social jess but a different jessica
from
the text messages
do you have any advice for cooking in
small kitchens especially when counter
space is limited um
so this is the perfect question for me
max because i have a tiny kitchen where
i live yeah we have like a 900 square
foot
apartment and but the kitchen itself is
hyper functional but really small and
it's a real pain where all three of us
me and my wife and my daughter are
trying to be in the kitchen together
it's always me my wife like she's
cooking i'm washing dishes and ella just
wants to like run through there with her
eyes closed and her arms out
and just see what she can disrupt and so
here's my pithy answer and then we can
we can talk about it my fifth answer is
countertop clutter constrains creativity
in the kitchen how's that for
alliteration
the big problem that we often have in
our kitchens is countertop clutter and
the reason we have that and this
permeates the rest of our homes as well
if we have flat surfaces we often feel
compelled to fill those flat surfaces
with things they become the destination
to set things on right yeah and so we
have only a few things on our kitchen
counter we have a paper towel holder
we have a coffee maker or a coffee
pot you know the water boiler and then
we have a coffee grinder as well
and that's all we have regularly
everything else has a home in a cabinet
now that makes it a little inconvenient
if we had a toaster for example i would
put it underneath the and every time i
need to use it i would pull it out and
then toast the bread we do this with the
insta pot we do this i mean everyone
does this with their skillets for the
most part right now you're not
constantly leaving everything piled on
top of your stove right
and so i find that the problem with
kitchen clutter often has to do with
actually having too much
counter space because then we feel
compelled to put all of our things
on the counters but if you say no to
that up front
you add a little bit of inconvenience a
little bit of friction it actually adds
a tremendous amount of calm to your
kitchen yeah
i mean i i think i suffer from from that
as well i mean because i have
what was important to me before moving
into the place that i'm currently in was
having a a lot of counter space because
i love cooking
and i create a lot of content in my
kitchen and um and i think you're right
it's a more counter space you have the
more inclined you are to put stuff on it
um
but uh but i think one of the one of the
best tips that i can give to people is
to clean as they go while they're
cooking which is not something that most
people do most people will cook and then
they save the cleanup for after dinner
which just makes it first of all it
makes it really intimidating from a
visual standpoint that's why i think
many people are inclined to put it off
until the next morning oh myself
included right i hate it yeah and then
you wake up to a mess you wake up to a
mess it's not a great way to start the
day
um
so i think getting into the habit of
cleaning as you go
whether you know you've just used a
knife and then you go and you rinse the
knife afterwards obviously with soap
requisite soap and water
or a if you're using a cutting board
which by the way i think is a wood
cutting board is another kitchen staple
next to the cast iron pan gotta have a
good wood cutting board it also doubles
it's one of these kitchen utensils that
has that has like a side hustle it's
obviously very useful as a cutting board
keeping your knives um in good shape
doubles the great serving platter for
meats and stuff i love to bring out like
a cooked rib eye or a rack of ribs on a
on the cutting board to the table as the
centerpiece so great um wiping that off
as you're
as you're using it um cleaning as you go
i think is a is a major
it helps from the standpoint of
like psychology right but it also helps
with time economy the economy of time
yeah
yeah ryan you got something fifty four
yeah my pithy answer is this it's not
the size of the space that matters
it's how you use it
you know i think that's so important it
really is no because like what you're
talking about with um everything having
a home in a cabinet where you're talking
about cleaning as you go what these are
boundaries these are things that uh
we've set up to help us have a
clutter-free kitchen so
again it doesn't matter the size of the
space it's how you use it what
boundaries have you set up for yourself
yeah and and by the way having a smaller
space forces you to have more boundaries
right because you just don't have this i
wish we had a slightly larger kitchen
because there are
it's a bit disorganized in one or two of
the cabinets in a way that i just
dislike
everything fits in there but i'd love to
have more space between my appliances
and and yet
we have enough space because
we've determined we can't overflow these
boundaries whatever boundaries we've set
up here we're not going to go beyond
that
we got a whole bunch more to talk about
ryan uh before we do that though real
quick right here right now one thing
going on in the life of the minimalists
this is coming out april 5th so we're
going back out on tour this month we had
to cancel to our last two american tour
stops because of weather yeah we're
gonna be in chicago and minneapolis this
month i think there's still a few
tickets left as of this recording come
on out say hi we got special guests in
both cities the minimalists.com tour
we're also going to be in canada later
this year you can find those dates over
there as well and recordings of all of
our previous live events over at
patreon.com slash the minimalist but
it's my favorite thing that we do in
fact well before we start recording
we're trying to talk max into maybe
bringing his podcast the the genius life
on the road as well
super down it looks i mean just from
social media it looks like you guys have
so much fun how it is the audience loves
it and i've never done like a a road
tour like taking taking my podcast the
genius life on the road so
well this is our 10th tour in 12 years
and i tell you it's been fun everything
every one of them has been different
it's just interesting how so like right
now we're recording this it's going out
to an audience but when you have the
audience like right there responding and
interacting with the podcast it just
yeah it's freaking awesome yeah it
really is it's our favorite thing ryan
gives a talk about minimalism he gets up
there and what's nice about this is
quite often people will drag a friend or
family member with them who's never
heard of minimalism and they keep
hearing their spouse their husband or
wife rave about this minimalist thing or
these minimalist guys or whatever
but they don't really have a clue and so
half the people in the audience are
really caught up there deep on the
podcast they know what's going on the
other half of the people are like hey
i'm just here i'm here to support my
spouse and what we love about is ryan
i'll catch him up to speed he'll give a
15-minute talk about minimalism what is
minimalism he'll hurl about 400 stats at
you
400.
the guinness record of stats he's not
minimalist with the stats no
no he is he's decluttering he's getting
them off the stage immediately
so many stats anyway i'll do a book
reading from our book love people use
things and then we do a live version of
the podcast we often have music to open
up the shows or we'll have a special
podcast guest during these events we did
20 for the love people use things tour
you can find those cities minneapolis
chicago toronto vancouver and we may be
doing a few other cities in canada as
well by the time this comes out the
minimalists.com
tour to find the city closest to you or
you can find recordings of live events
over there as well alabama what else you
got for us here are some of them
voicemail comments and insights from our
listeners
hey josh and ryan this is andy from
portland oregon
i wanted to call to give you guys a
packing tip
so i have done a lot of traveling in my
life i used to travel for work four to
five days a week
and since then now i just travel for fun
usually
but one of the best things that i came
across
to really minimize what i travel with
is to pack in advance to try to pack for
my trip
a couple days and really lay out my
outfits for each day see what items i
can mix and match then i put it all in
the suitcase and i wait
and then two days before the trip i'll
go in and say what can i remove what do
i not think that i'll need
i find that when i revisit my outfits or
my planning that it's easier for me to
take out a couple excess items
i like to consider myself somewhat
fashionable so whether it's
a bag or a pair of shoes or a shirt i
usually find that i can take out one or
two items
this has allowed me to go to china and
russia for three weeks both for fun and
for work all in a carry-on
hi this is tracy from new jersey and i'm
responding to amy's dilemma with the
pictures that she had from the passing
of her father
this happened to us a few years ago when
my husband's parents both died within a
short span of each other
and we took all of the pictures from
their home in order to try to organize
them for the family
what worked really well for us
is i went through the pictures instead
of him because i was more dispassionate
about it
the pictures didn't hold a lot of
memories for me
and i think he would have agonized over
each and every photo
the first thing i did is i separated any
photo that didn't have people in it and
i got rid of them
my
in-laws loved taking pictures of
landscapes and flowers and birds and
they were beautiful but they had no
meaning to us at all i'm sure they gave
hit my in-laws great pleasure but they
didn't hold any meaning for us so those
immediately went
the pictures that were left had people
in them
and i sat down with my husband and i
said identify the people so i can write
it on the back and if he didn't know who
the people were the picture went it
obviously again held no meaning for him
there were a few that we reached out to
his siblings and said do you know who
these people are and if we could
identify them it went into the keep pile
then finally we went to the keep pile
and we looked for things that were
similar if there were 10 pictures from a
party nine of them probably went
and doing this over a period of about
two weeks we whittled the pictures down
about 95 and the ones that were left we
scanned and we made an album a digital
album and we gave a copy to each of our
siblings
this worked really well
it brought up a lot of nice memories and
it saved my husband the agony of going
through each and every picture
all right y'all big thanks to max
lugavir for joining us today he'll be
with us on the maximum episode uh turn
to the wide shot jordan no more if you
take a look we our desk right now is
full it's cluttered with snacks we're
gonna have a feast oh well i don't we're
gonna make max eat all of these that's
on camera we're gonna have a snack
eating contest an asmr
edition
he'll be chewing the what is that a
crunch bar i don't know anyway i'm gonna
have you scrutinize these tell me what
is amazing tell me what is less amazing
we've got so much stuff here this is
literally i just went downstairs into
our little shared kitchenette area and
got whatever snacks that we have this is
what we provide for the team to snack on
whenever they would like yeah and so uh
we're going to talk about that on the
maxwell episode check out his book
though it is called genius kitchen it is
300 pages of simple recipes kitchen
hacks and nutrition tips that you won't
find anywhere else you can also check
out his podcast it's called geniuslife
we'll put a link to both of those in the
show notes you can also follow max on
instagram and twitter i think it's just
at max lugavir both right yeah correct
max thanks so much for being here thanks
for having me man you're awesome well
for our added value segment this week
ryan since um
dieting can often be like a roller
coaster yes and we're going to talk a
lot about food on the maximal episode i
thought we'd end this minimal episode
today well if you listen to the audio
version with a lumineer song lumineers
just has they have a new album that just
came out and the album is called bright
side and this song is called roller
coaster
if you're watching the youtube version i
think you can click up here right jordan
does that work you click up here and
there's going to be a video that you can
listen to here's a roller coaster from
lumineers by the way max we got a bunch
more surprise questions this week like
is the most minimalist diet vegan keto
or paleo what food should we completely
remove from our diet plus a million more
questions for max and the minimalist if
you want to hear all that check out the
minimalist private podcast this week
visit patreon.com the minimalist to
subscribe and get your personal link so
that our weekly private podcast plays in
your favorite podcast app you also gain
immediate access to hundreds of hours of
private archives recordings of live
events exclusive home tours and our
private community of thousands of
open-minded minimizers like you you can
follow the minimalists on tick tock
instagram facebook and twitter at the
minimalists if you want our podcast show
notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list over at the
minimalists.com on behalf of ryan
nicodemus podcast sean alabama jordan no
more social jess danny unknown emma the
immigrant and the rest of our team i'm
joshua fields-milburn reminding you to
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for being here y'all see you next
time
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine
without it